[Música]
la entrevista de france 24 l es la
primera y más de francia y aboga por un
islam de paz claro y reforma y
reformista el islah molo ga y fundadora
de la mezquita fátima página pública y
es nuestra invitada de hoy javi gracias
por acompañar universidad a vic núm el
gobierno francés presentó su proyecto de
ley donde consolida los principios
republicanos más transparencia en los
puntos justos control reforzado de la
financiación extranjera un delito para
reprimir el odio por internet o incluso
prohibición para los profesionales de la
salud de establecer certificados de
virginidad que piensan acerca de estas
nuevas medidas anunciadas por el
gobierno mismo
hola a todos y muchas gracias por
haberme invitado a su programa en vista
del contexto del islamismo que ganó
agresividad por decirlo así en los
últimos tiempos a través de los
atentados terroristas que se han
cometido en el territorio francés
creo que de todas maneras es muy normal
que el estado francés proponga
soluciones es muy normal el estatut así
normales y creo que algunas de ellas van
en el buen sentido los bolsones notamos
en particular respecto al control de la
educación de los
y que según ustedes cuales irían en el
mal sentido y cuáles serían en el bueno
en realidad creo que lo que no va por el
buen sentido es todo lo que está
relacionado con el control de la
financiación al culto musulmán en france
todos sabemos que hace unos días el
presidente de la república le pidió al c
fcm crear un consejo nacional de imanes
por ejemplo y en realidad creo que el
verdadero problema está más bien a ese
nivel a nivel de la representatividad
del islam de francia hoy en día sabemos
que el cfcm es una institución muy
frágil sabemos que fue creado por
federaciones que están ellas mismas bajo
influencia extranjera bajo la influencia
de argelia marruecos y turquía lo cual
no favorece para nada el surgimiento de
un islam de praxis al oeste de este
acuerdo para quienes no lo conocen el
cfs ms el consejo francés del culto
musulmán cuyo objetivo es representar a
los musulmanes de francia sin embargo
una de las medidas anunciadas apunta a
controlar las donación
las extranjeras de más de diez mil euros
qué piensas sobre esta medida
eso está bien pero pienso que de todas
maneras es totalmente insuficiente el
verdadero problema está a nivel de una
organización mucho más amplia más global
de la financiación del culto musulmán en
francia a través de la creación de
instituciones adecuadas que trabajen con
el estado pero por un mejor control de
esos flujos financieros y también para
detener toda influencia extranjera y
poder llegar finalmente a detener
cualquier tipo de influencia y de
financiación proveniente del extranjero
y hoy en día es posible comprobar que no
hemos llegado a ellos
habría usted ha añadido otras
disposiciones que recomendaciones les
haría al gobierno y a los legisladores
bueno mi recomendación es justamente van
en ese sentido en cuanto al trabajo en
cuanto a una reforma de la
representatividad del islam de francia
creo que realmente ahí está el mayor
problema en cuanto a la
representatividad debería ser posible
extenderla e incluir a los intelectuales
a la corriente liberal y reformista que
nosotros representamos la cual hoy en
día no es consultada
cuando el estado trabaja con el cfc es
que las mujeres también juegan un papel
en esta reflexión sobre el islam en
francia ojos
esto me parece totalmente evidente
actualmente estamos en francia estamos
en un país democrático que debe defender
las libertades individuales pero también
la igualdad entre hombres y mujeres y lo
que vemos actualmente es que en lo que
respecta al islam el estado realmente no
está jugando ese papel
porque finalmente le delega a todo ese
asunto por ejemplo la gestión de la mamá
o la gestión del culto musulmán en
francia al cfs
que está constituido por federaciones
que siguen estando bajo la influencia de
países musulmanes de origen y es
necesario saber que esos países tienen
unas lecturas muy conservadoras del
islam y no permiten ninguna lectura
reformista ni liberal del islam
cajina basilio ustedes misma se inscribe
en la tradición sufí podría explicarles
brevemente a nuestros telespectadores
cómo se define el sufismo en particular
en relación con las otras grandes
corrientes del islam
no se podría decir exactamente que el
sufismo es una corriente entre otras del
islam yo creo que se debe hablar más
bien de dimensiones de dimensiones
espirituales del islam porque por
ejemplo se conocen las distintas
escuelas que constituyen la
jurisprudencia musulmana o lo que
llamamos el derecho o el film musulmán
constituido por las cuatro escuelas
tradicionales que conocemos y de las
cuales la escuela malikí es la que
actualmente está en vigor es magreb por
ejemplo
pero el sufismo no se sitúa para nada a
ese nivel es necesario saber que después
de la revelación coránica emergieron
distintas disciplinas religiosas que se
apoyan sobre el texto coránico y sobre
la tradición profética pero hay varias
disciplinas está la jurisprudencia está
la teología racional está la filosofía y
luego está la dimensión mística que está
representada por el sufismo entonces yo
hablaría más bien de la dimensión
espiritual del islam
y usted aboga por reformar es decirlo
así el islam con base de los textos
fundacionales propone una nueva lectura
de los textos ext
por supuesto así es creo que esa es la
apuesta del islam a actualmente vemos
todo lo que se expresa hoy en día piense
a través de los movimientos
fundamentalistas integristas que de
alguna manera quieren volver a instaurar
un islam de los orígenes completamente
mitificado y fantasmagoría que en
realidad no existe sólo existe en sus
imaginarios entonces es absolutamente
necesario lograr hoy en día proponer una
reforma de la lectura y de la
interpretación de los textos
fundacionales del islam para eso es
absolutamente necesario utilizar
nuestras herramientas actuales es decir
las ciencias humanas y sociales que se
desarrollan en el seno de nuestras
universidades de las universidades
occidentales en algunos países
extranjeros se ha oído decir que francia
maltratar sus musulmanes hay una
incomprensión de la necesidad a la
francesa y cité a las voces
en efecto creo que en el extranjero y
una incomprensión de lo que es la
laicidad a la francesa es verdad que se
tiene la impresión de que es un poco muy
dura
sí probablemente haya una incomprensión
pero tal vez también hay un trabajo por
hacer en francia para explicar mejor
cuál es el papel de esta laicidad que no
está ahí para impedir la libertad de
creer o de no creer o de practicar su
religión como uno la empieza sino es más
bien lo contrario es garantizar la
libertad de culto mientras por supuesto
se controla mientras se le da la
posibilidad al estado de controlar que
las religiones se práctico respetando el
orden público
la mencioné en la introducción usted es
la primera imán de francia
sus acciones le molestan a algunas
personas a menudo recibe insultos
incluso a veces hasta amenazas
pareciera que todavía hay un camino por
recorrer para que las mujeres imanes que
sean aceptadas
sí creo que sigue habiendo un largo
camino todavía por recorrer pero esa es
justamente toda la apuesta de la lectura
reformista de la que le hablaba en
realidad esta lectura ya se había
iniciado hace siglos por pensadores
musulmanes como muhammad abdul en egipto
en el siglo 19 por ejemplo y por otros
por ejemplo tájar ha quedado en túnez
pero desafortunadamente estos pensadores
son totalmente desconocidos por el gran
público por los musulmanes y de hecho
nuestro objetivo hoy en día también es
difundir y volver un poco más accesible
ese pensamiento que finalmente sólo se
quedó en los libros en las esferas
intelectuales y fue completamente
dominado por las lecturas integristas y
fundamentalistas
domínguez para la elección ante crisis
de fondo no está listo
gracias caminaba julio gracias por
habernos acompañado de la entrevista de
france 24 días y gracias a ustedes por
habernos resintonizar está muy
prontamente
[Música]